des journaux gratuits que les gens
s'arrachent
le temps des désastres
en une heure ce sont vingt-cinq mille
exemplaires de 20 minutes qui
disparaissent c'est le plus gros point
de distribution de la capitale une image
qui date aujourd'hui les journaux
gratuits ont presque tous disparu
pourtant à leur arrivée ils avaient
réussi de suite à conquérir les français
ces pratiques alliés dans l'air
on arrive à lire en 20 minutes il ya des
choses qui sont si bien vite sur les
journaux qu'on paie
tous les jours métro et 20 minutes
faisait aussi trembler les gros titres
de la presse nationale qui dénonçait une
presse au rabais il faut savoir que
c'est pas ça un journal voilà c'est un
journal si on à 250 journée c'est parce
que on fait partie des très grosses
rédaction
la presse écrit elle a une capacité à la
fois de produire d'information d'analysé
de décrypter d'anticiper des choses sont
des sous journaux et je soupçonne leurs
initiateurs devait faire pour un sou
public malgré ces critiques la presse
gratuite séduit 20 minutes s'impose
désormais comme le premier quotidien
généraliste de france avec près de deux
millions de lecteurs metronomy se classe
4e juste derrière le monde et le
parisien en 2002 c'est le leitmotiv ça
ne marchera jamais
en 2004 2005 tiens ils sont encore
vivants et en 2006 zut ils réussissent
ils réussissent à tel point que ceux qui
les avaient critiqué s'associe à l'image
du monde en 2007 voici matin plus votre
nouveau journal d'information lancée par
le mével héros alors ce n'est pas avec
paul héraud mais bien avec vincent
bolloré que le monde s'associent pour
lancer matin plus une question de survie
selon le quotidien un moyen aussi
approché des lecteurs plus jeunes mais
voilà en 2014 conséquence de la crise
économique
les publicitaires sert les budgets et
les premiers impacts et la presse
gratuite dont le modèle économique
repose entièrement sur les annonceurs
notre enquête de ce dimanche quel avenir
pour les journaux gratuits eux aussi
sont touchés par la crise les éditions
papier de métro disparaissent en 2015
matin plus qui s'est transformé en ces
news s'est arrêtée en décembre 2021 il
ne reste plus que 20 minutes en édition
réduite la pandémie aura été loquace
[Musique]